hi everyone Sal Khan here from Khan
Academy and I just want to first of all
express my gratitude to all of you who
have supported Khan Academy over the
years and I also wanted to reach out to
those of y'all who haven't because as
you know we are not for profit with a
mission of providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere and it
wouldn't be possible without donations
from folks like yourself as I tell folks
we are an organization with a budget of
about a large high school but our goal
is literally free world-class education
for anyone anywhere to be an institution
that can serve billions of people for
generations and as important as Khan
Academy was during the pandemic at the
peak of the pandemic we saw our usage go
from 30 million learning minutes a day
to almost 90 million learning minutes as
we know the post-pandemic period that we
are hopefully entering into now is the
period where we really need to make sure
that students all over the country in
the US and and all over the world have
the opportunity to finish their
unfinished learning and accelerate to
where they need to go and what you're
going to see with your support if we're
able to get it is a lot of really cool
Innovations over the coming years we are
continuing to expand the content that we
offer many folks know us for our math
videos they don't realize we have a full
Mastery based math exercise a framework
that starts in pre-k with Khan Academy
kids and goes all the way to calculus
and statistics and Beyond we are doing a
big push in science all of the Sciences
in middle school and high school and
early college we would like if we get
the resources to do a push in English
and language arts we're going to be
doing a push in Civics we're going to
think about how can we personalize
things better for students really start
to emulate what a good tutor would do
for them and at the same time how can we
better assist teachers inside of
classrooms and classrooms are where
we're going to we think we're going to
make huge gains an efficacy study just
came out it's one of over 5 50 efficacy
studies on Khan Academy that if students
are able to put in even 30 to 60 Minutes
a week not per day per week it's going
to accelerate them
20 30 40 percent more than pre-pandemic
Norms during the pandemic most students
saw a decline this efficacy study was
run during the pandemic in 8th graders
which is actually where you normally see
the biggest decline saw a 40
acceleration and that's once again 30 to
60 Minutes a week or about 18 hours over
over the course of a whole school year
so if you're a big believer in serving
folks all over the world helping them
reach their potential if you're a user
of Khan Academy and if you would like to
see us build out our content build out
our engagement build out our efficacy
and even more make it possible so that
work on Khan Academy can lead to high
school and college credit we have a
pilot with Howard University right now
where students in Title 1 high schools
they get Mastery in college algebra on
Khan Academy take the Howard midterm and
final they're getting transferable
college algebra credit we want to expand
that to more more subjects more grades
so as you can see the journey at Khan
Academy as far as we have gone the the
tens or hundreds of millions that we've
already served our aspirations are much
much bigger we want to be the safety net
education system for the world and
ideally when students do have great
schools environments to be in we hope to
supercharge it to allow more
personalization so that every student
can reach their potential thank you